i'm very lucky i've been part of two
unicorns i was part of
um fun tech in israel i was part of
ernext in israel that both became
unicorns
and actually i started to look for my
next role one of the key things i was
looking was to have purpose
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
honored to be joined by peter reynolds
the chief revenue officer of theta ray
but his journey is much more than that
an accomplished fintech executive and
global sales leader with extensive
experience building world-class and
high-performing revenue organizations
that achieve hyper growth
peter brings two decades of experience
selling enterprise software into
financial institutions fintechs and
global corporations and has end-to-end
accountability for federalist revenue
organization
prior to joining federer as chief
revenue officer peter started his career
with hsbc before holding senior sales
leadership positions at ernex
tech reval and thompson financial
peter is a regular contributor to the
industry dialogue as a well-respected
thought leader he holds a law degree
from london guild hall university this
is really an interesting conversation
about a revenue chief revenue officer
different career trajectories and how
peter sees his own career in the world
enjoy
i appreciate you coming here and
spending these 20 minutes talking a
little bit about your own journey today
is uh today is chief revenue officer in
the fintech and ai space um very very
interesting space that we're seeing
unfold over these last few years and and
you have a very
non-trivial career trajectory uh
starting out from a from pretty
interesting story that i have to start
with um it has to do with the army your
brother and the in the interview tell me
a little bit about that
yeah
so i didn't do as well as my uh you know
my uh a levels what you'd call college i
didn't quite get the grades i needed to
go to law school
um so my parents were away one summer
and i thought uh i thought i'd take the
i don't know if i at the time i thought
it was the easy way out and go and join
the military uh i'm kind of
don't think it would have been the easy
way out at all number one but luckily i
had an older brother who while i was
kind of uh out with friends
actually applied to a different law
school did the interview for me and i
came back and uh after
kind of a few nights of partying and
wondering what to do with my life and my
big brother said to me were you going to
law school so uh that was that and uh
kind of led to a what i would say a
career of falling into the right thing
at the right time it's done me well that
amazing and so
if you're now
looking at a little bit more broadly
about you know your career and uh all
the way leading up to today's sierra of
cetera
how do you
reason through it sort of
what what is what is sort of the guiding
star for you as you're going through
these different organizations that that
all seem to have you know a similar
path and are dealing with similar issues
but what is sort of your north star as
you're navigating through them
yeah um so look i i do put a lot of what
i have achieved as being in the right
place at the right time
but i also believe that you put yourself
in the right place at the right time so
i i would honestly say that if you were
to meet
any ceo i've ever worked for they would
tell you that i've been aiming at
becoming a cro you know since day one
i i was kind of lucky i i fell out of
kind of i fell into investment banking
out of law school working for hsbc
in the times when there were lots of
jobs in finance so it was fairly easy to
get a job
enjoyed it but didn't it wasn't really
me the kind of stuffy environment of of
a of a british investment bank
and and what really fell into what was
my first sales role in technology which
was thompson financial now now thompson
reuters
and sold terminals and and absolutely
loved it knew nothing about it was kind
of given the role by a friend of a
friend
seemed to be quite good at sales and
then from there really fell into what
was software as a service it was a
a coincidental meeting one of the
partners of thompson financial was a
derivative risk management startup
called reval that sold this thing called
software as a service there'd been a
number of accounting scandals in the
world that i knew nothing about like
enron
and there was a change in how corporates
and banks had to account for derivatives
and risk
and i i got to know the ceo of this
company and he said look why don't you
set us up in in europe i think i was
like 23 at the time i didn't really know
what that meant i didn't really know
what options were but he said you know
come and come and do this
and it led to probably the best learning
of my life which was 10 years going from
a
you know a sales executive through to
running sales and everything in between
in a high growth private equity backed
organization so i think that's
kind of gave me the foundation for
everything else i've done in my life
amazing and and the fascination with
fintech and ai and and that intersection
was that something that that was coming
from before was that something that
you've
started to understand more and more as
you were continuing with your career
yeah i suppose i knew nothing about
technology as i went into it i think
what i learned
one of the biggest things i learned in
my days at reval was that there's
something a problem a business has
that they need to solve and that
technology will solve it and the the
whole emergence of what we used to call
internet-based technology or or cloud as
it became cooler and then software as a
service
was a very easy way for companies to do
things that were quite complex
in a fairly easy way
so that kind of grew from there into the
payment space and into ai and now i'm
absolutely um you know fully focused on
how
this industry can help very large
organizations
take something that's a well-known
concept like ai but put it into
production and actually start using it
in production rather than so many
companies that talk a good game but
don't actually use it
and so where are we at today in your
perspective and
fintech and ai
yeah i mean it's it's it's fascinating
so i'm the the cro of theta and theta
is an incredibly interesting
organization
we help fintechs we help large banks we
help governments
protect against things they're not meant
to do such as they're not having they
don't need to have money laundering they
don't need terrorism funding they can't
be
you know helping with the proceeds of
drug trafficking
any kind of people traffic anything like
that
and we use ai in production to actually
help them protect against that
so if you think about what i've just
said this is a very regulated
environment so this is something where
regulators really watch and see what
people are doing and make sure they do
it well enough
and so what i've seen in the last few
years is this move from
ai being a buzzword that everyone wants
to play with in the innovation
department of every organization
to ai becoming game-changing in mission
critical activities such as
you know how can we identify the
difference between a payment michael's
making and the payment a terrorist
organization is making they might look
the same they might feel the same
that's a huge leap forward in the in ai
being a genuine benefit to society and
to banks and to payments and to fintechs
and everything else that we talk about
now is this transition from buzzword to
production ready
is that mainly a you know matter of
technology being ready and accessible or
is there or are there different shifts
in consumer behavior that are allowing
for these types of technologies to be
adopted into
into these companies
look there's three huge things going on
at the moment and number one of course
you've got an improvement in ai
no doubt you've got
improvement in technologies that make it
something you can do that said a lot of
what we're doing at the moment you could
have done
years ago but it's something that maybe
the market is now ready to understand
and explain but you know take a step
back what's happened in the world so
firstly we've got digitization and
cross-border payments right if i want to
pay you some money from london to where
you are in palo alto it's going to go
through about four or five different
banks and each of those banks are going
to be liable for you and i being good
people and the payment being something
that we should accept now that's not
possible unless you use things like ai
so it's become needed
and then i think more importantly look
a year ago this space was interesting
a year ago you saw banks getting
multi-million dollar fines you saw
all sorts going on in the market
now we're in a situation where
rightly or wrongly but you know global
governments have decided to fight war
using things like sanctions so now you
are seeing government saying hey
you might not be allowed to
accept transactions from this person
this group this region whatever it might
be
now if you think about how you might do
that as a bank if you had individuals
involved
you just the the experience would be
crazy for anyone who wanted to use that
financial institution
and the cost of actually running that
would be
not even possible so this has led to a
need to use technology and ai to
actually say okay well we need to look
for certain things how do we do that
let's use ai to do that rather than you
know humans and that's where i think
there's has been and you'll see a an
explosion in this space
but if we're even looking at a solution
like the one that third ray provides i
mean we're looking at you know these
really
meaningful questions that you're asking
some of them are are critical decision
making points for these organizations
and it almost feels like the these
organizations are you know depending on
on a third party to provide them the
insight and the intelligence sometimes
to determine whether something is as
critical as you know a fraudulent uh
fraudulent payment or wrong transaction
or a group that we don't or a
transaction that we don't want to find
in fund in general
that's a lot of responsibility on that
third party is there really willingness
in the market for these institutions to
outsource that type of decision making
that previously was probably done by
thousands of bankers
yeah great great question and i think
the way i see it is that most of the
noise
i have the privilege of talking to
fintechs and banks every day and most of
the noise at the banks is that if you
think about the alternative first so
let's say you've got
some i don't know sanctions checking so
hey someone with this name we should
stop using our financial institution i
think people have come to terms with the
fact that that might be easy to beat
right i don't think you know that that's
not the hardest thing for a criminal to
get around
so then you go to what happened around
you know 20 30 years ago as people
started using rules-based systems to say
if a b and c happen we might want to
look at that transaction
the problem then you have and this is
the problem that all of the financial
institutions have or the small
nimble firms they get caught up in so
much noise so much is so much what we
call false positives that they end up
having huge labor forces looking into
everything and firstly that costs a lot
of money and secondly you know michael
who's trying to make a payment is
annoyed that it's taking three days
there's noise that it's costing him 50
bucks to make a payment
so i think where the application of ai
comes into play and into its own
isn't necessarily making the decision
it's getting rid of the noise it's
learning and it's saying
hey mr bank these are the transactions
you should look at so firstly we we
limit the
volume of noise to something that's very
manageable and secondly as we start
saying is this bad is this good the
model keeps getting better and better so
that even if all you're going to say is
we can reduce operational overheads by
using the um the ai this is the kind of
thing that we see a lot of um
benefit from and i think that's
something that's game changing to a big
organization
right and so
the interesting distinction here is
you're saying that you know it there's a
lot of value in simply
ranking and prioritizing on where the
where the decision making is taking
place and so there's you know there's a
there's a variety of of where the
company like fedora can interject itself
into the chain of of decision making
within an organization from ranking to
decision making and obviously with the
models getting better and better tell me
a little bit about theater as a as a
company in the space and what is sort of
the grander vision of of what is
possible leveraging ai in the fintech
space
yeah uh great question and thank you
definitely i'll cover that so theta is a
very very interesting organization
that's been around
actually more years than you might think
and it it started
using and aren't solving problems around
big bats of data and looking for
for different problems with data that
might be apparent to an airline to a to
a bank and for a long time it was
solving a number of problems about three
years ago it got very focused on um what
was very important to us which is this
cross-border payments payments
so i think to us what we're looking at
is is you know a few decades ago
the payment infrastructure of the world
so how i pay you
was
advanced to what was sort of thought as
safe so there was the swift network for
example but since then nothing's
happened and our the vision we have is
how do you put trust in the payment
network so how does your bank know where
you're sending money
is trustworthy and that they can let
straight through process and they can
let flow which is what we all want
there's a lot of good people around the
world who need to make payments it's
it's it's a multi-trillion dollar
industry
but how do we weed out the bad now what
we can't do if you think about the way
we've been doing it in the past we can't
rely on a on a name or we can't rely on
certain things like just for example if
you went to an airport and you had a
name on your bag and it was a good name
we wouldn't just chuck it on the plane
and say oh i'm sure this is fine and
just the same if it had a different name
and we wouldn't blow it up what we do is
we span all transactions we look for
things that might be a problem and when
we have a problem we look at them but if
there's no problem we let them flow and
this is this is the vision we have for
the organization is how do you put trust
in the payment network so if i'm a bank
if i'm a bank in south africa and i have
payments coming from michael through
correspondent banks that are going on to
tanzania how do i know to let them go
and reduce the cost of that process but
only to look at the ones that actually
me my regulator my my board want us to
look into to make sure we're not
facilitating things we shouldn't
right and
what is the potential here so if we're
looking at the the scale because you
know the the world the fintech is
exploding one as the world becomes more
globalized and and money can travel
across border i mean the opportunities
are endless but is there some
understanding of what what what these
companies
how many transactions these could happen
what is the rate of growth you know some
indications of
is there a glass ceiling even to what
are you doing here
yeah the market is is phenomenally big
you know i'm i let me take a step back
i'm i'm very lucky i've been part of two
unicorns i was part of
um fun tech in israel i was part of
ernext in israel that both became
unicorns
and actually i started to look for my
next role one of the key things i was
looking was to have purpose yes i wanted
it to scale but i wanted to be involved
in something that you know gave back you
know did something good and very
positive for society i'm not saying the
other companies didn't but what i'm
saying is is that it's a very nice
conversation when you're talking to
fintechs and banks and governments about
how they stop people trafficking that's
a good conversation to have and it makes
you feel very warm inside that you're
having that conversation
but as i've as i was joining and as i've
joined i've realized that this is
definitely going to be the biggest
company i've ever been part of
when you sell to the fintechs and and
one of the things we have is we have a
machine that sells to the the fintechs
around the world and we we start working
with new organizations on a weekly basis
you know a company that
just the other day in the us we had a
company that found us uh and signed up
within 10 days and and michael you've
been in technology to know enough when
you're a cro and you can see how
companies can find you and sign
agreements in 10 days this is something
that you want to recreate so
in terms of scale we have this machine
that brings
fintech organizations on board very very
quickly which is great
and then on top of that we have the big
significant organization so there are
very large organizations that use
large global banks that use us globally
and of course that scale of that's huge
and we also have governments that use us
to actually check that the transactions
that the banks are doing are also the
ones they should be doing
so when i look at that and you talk
about scale
it's amazing you know it's it's one of
the things is that think about
cross-border payments cross-border
payments are going to
absolutely keep growing you know in an
exponential amount and and rate because
the world's becoming so cross-border
right that we don't any i don't operate
you don't operate in a world that has
barriers and where we find barriers we
don't like them if you go to your bank
today and they say it's going to cost
you 40 bucks to make a payment to the uk
it's going to take you 15 seconds to
download an app that's going to charge
you two bucks and you're gonna do it and
that's what's powering this kind of
exponential kind of growth in this area
incredible and peter it sounds like
right field right time um and uh and
obviously i mean it says a lot that
you've been a part of so many incredible
organizations and i think that the more
that you think about where the world is
heading and the opportunities that ai
presents i think it's it's it's it's
it's almost um
too much to understand and to fathom but
i think if you look really tangibly at
some of the core problems that you that
we presented here this this idea of can
we leverage ai not to necessarily
replace but to augment existing
processes something as
you know as simple as as ranking the
priorities of what to look at and i
think it's you know a lot of people tend
to go to the extreme and say okay no no
way we can't trust this machine to go
and replace these thousands of bankers
but they don't realize okay there is
actually some space in between in which
these machines can augment the
can augment the banker's behavior and
and eliminate the problem of of human
resources essentially and and reduce
that problem and so and that was just a
tiny part of what we talked about
something that specifically i'm taking
with me and peter i really want to thank
you for your time and your energy and
and was really really enjoyable on my
end and it sounds fascinating work and
an even more fascinating journey overall
so thank you very much for coming and
sharing it with me and stay safe and
stay healthy and best of luck with
federer
thank you very much michael look forward
to listening to your next podcast
[Music]